First is Spanish colony.
Then in American one Puerto Rico,
a small islands in the Caribbean.
It defines itself as a free state
associated with the United States
Associated State who citizens have
American citizenship,
but unless they move to another state,
cannot vote in the presidential
elections,
and even though they have a
representative in Congress,
he also lacks a vote.
Yeah,
well,
the major issues be they political,
economic or military lions at the
federal jurisdiction of the United
States.
Lately,
there's been a lot of talk about this
territory.
Not only because in September of 2017
they suffered the harsh impacts of
Hurricane Maria,
but also because a few months before in
May of that same year,
Puerto Rico declared itself bankrupts.
After more than 10 years of economic
crisis sweater,
Rico's public accounts could no longer
keep going.
This is because the island's public
dense deposit is $70 billion,
ends another $50 billion in future
payment commitments such as pensions,
Stevia,
we're talking about figures that are
huge for an island.
The belly has more than 3 million
inhabitants because of this.
In recent years,
Puerto Rico has become known source of
as the grease of the Caribbean.
The simple fact of the matter is,
dear viewer,
Puerto Rico is insolvent,
but how exactly did they get to this
point?
Well,
listen up.
Okay,
let me,
that is a lot of discussion going on
about how to solve Puerto Rico's serious
crisis and how to stop the exodus that
the island is suffering,
which we saw in a previous video,
but first of all,
to address this issue,
I think we need to answer a question and
that's of course what I'll know if it
happens.
Yeah.
What caused pressure rico to become
quite soon in Sylvan?
What led to it becoming such a broke
island?
Well,
of course the grade culprit here is the
Puerto Rican government itself.
The government that has been spending
uncontrollably for decades and has many
suspicions of corruption as an absolute
disdain for production.
The going beyond his Puerto Rico's
government.
Washington also holds a large amount of
responsibility for this whole mess.
Washington's responsibilities.
In fact,
so great that it wouldn't be
unreasonable to save that the federal
government has been the main driver of
Puerto Rico's bankruptcy.
Yep.
You heard that right?
The United States says bombarded Puerto
Rico with five policies whose results
were absolutely devastating.
Five policies concerning trade
regulations,
salaries and welfare.
And if you don't believe me,
yes.
Well,
keep on listening.
It's free debt with this supposed
intention of aiding the Puerto Rican
economy and helping it's government
access the capital markets at the dawn
of the Jones Schaffrath Act,
Washington creators,
a triple municipal state and federal
exemption on Puerto Rico's debts
interests.
Thus,
if any US citizen purchased Puerto
Rico's public desk,
he or she was exempt from paying taxes
on the interest that was received.
In other words,
if an American bought a dance from a
company,
they had to pay taxes on the returns
that they obtained.
But if he or she invested in the debt of
Puerto Rico's politicians,
he or she didn't have to pay any tax at
all.
So you might imagine that with such
attractive conditions,
people would be queuing up to lend money
to the islands governments.
It was easy money.
The local politicians didn't take long
to spend and it was aimed at achieving a
single objective and that was winning or
should they really say buying votes?
I mean,
what better scenario could we can cox
for irresponsible politicians acts
engineering still logic while the
federal government's encouraged the
island to get deeply indebted,
it also made things harder for the
private economy.
In 2006 Congress abolish the so called
section nine three six of the tax code,
a section that provided significant
benefits for the companies that invested
in the islands.
And let's not forget here that Puerto
Rico is the poorest territory in the
United States.
Well,
the fact is that this incentive model,
it was very,
very successful,
but years it helps Puerto Rico grow a
loss even leading to it becoming a
manufacturing and pharmaceutical
powerhouse.
The ones,
the incentives were gone in 2006 two
years before the great international
financial crisis,
Puerto Rico began to fall into the best
overnight to the condition of the
companies that had been supporting.
Puerto Rico changed drastically,
forcing investments in the island to
sync legal security.
And it was a bit of a joke,
but that's not even close to being all
hair merchant,
marine law,
maybe the most controversial points of
all and at the same time it's the most
absurd law.
The Jones Act,
which passed in 1920 and distill in
force for bids,
foreign flag vessels from transporting
goods between two United States ports.
Thus they ship loaded with containers
coming from China cannot stop in Puerto
Rico because it has to continue on to
the mainland.
They're the container is destined for
Puerto Rico are unloaded and then loaded
onto another ship.
This time with a US flag and crew,
which is obviously very expensive.
It's like what's the result of all of
this?
What Question Rico?
It has the most expensive shipping costs
of all Caribbean countries.
It's something that not only industry
but also he makes exports more expensive
and reduces every prayer to wrekin's
purchasing power.
In fact,
fax it
to get an idea of this loss
implications.
We should mention that evenly.
Puerto Rico has an average income,
approximately half of that of
Mississippi and is poorer than any state
in the United States.
It's cost of living surpasses the
average state.
All of this leads to a really crazy
situation.
Minimum wage and welfare policy,
uh,
full of that wasn't enough.
Believe me,
there is more.
The average salary in Puerto Rico is the
same as the federal minimum wage.
That is $7 and 25 cents per hour.
The thing is that as we've seen,
both the development level and the
average income in Puerto Rico are much
lower than those of the US states
causing this policies distorting effects
to be,
well,
pretty enormous.
Okay.
You see the federal minimum wage in New
York or Illinois,
matter of fact,
very few people,
but in Puerto Rico it's really
different.
The federal minimum wage is the
equivalent of 77% of the average salary
in Puerto Rico.
That is the average salary of every
profession and every job on the island.
This is led only one in three people of
working age to actually do so.
And if this number,
it wasn't already abnormally low,
over a quarter of people with jobs,
I think worked for the government.
This means that less than 25% of the
island's population works in the actual
productive economy.
On the other hand,
the federal regulation also implies an
abnormally high level of social benefits
for Puerto Rico's parameters.
In fact,
studies show that for many families it
is more convenient to receive social
aids than to actually go to work because
the income they'll receive is
substantially higher.
Well,
folks,
the results of these five federal
policies has led to a huge crisis,
a crisis that has lasted more than 10
years,
which has caused or has at least fuels
the island's bankruptcy and just
generated a gigantic exodus of people
who escaped to the consonants,
especially of course the youngest.
As we saw here on visual politic in a
previous video,
I need the last 10 years,
500,000
Puerto Rican stuff,
packed their bags and to moved to the
continents.
That's one in every seven people.
There's a lot of talk about how to solve
the island's problems,
but the question is,
is Puerto Rico's current connection with
the United States compatible with any of
these solutions?
Well,
leave your answer to that in the
comments below,
as well as in this survey.
And so I really hope you enjoyed that
video.
If you did,
please do hit that like button and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
brand new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsidered media
podcasts,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that are not mine,
and as always,
thank you for watching.